hey youtubers I call this meeting of the
jon snow truthers to order just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen episode
2 yet so here we go biggest surprise of
the episode was they did the thing this
soon totally was not expecting this to
happen for at least another episode or
two just because of some of the big
reveals we know are coming my tower of
joy for instance now you can go to all
your friends who do not believe in r
plus l equals j and just start pointing
towards like look at this evidence see
everything is lining up all the stuff
they seeded in season 5 so I'll explain
all that stuff will go through top 10
WTF but lots of big stuff happening we
met your on Greyjoy for the first time
it's gonna be so much fun I am the storm
so let's go number 10 we're would
flashback number 1 we get to see young
Ned fighting young Brandon Stark his
older brother Lyanna Stark shows up so
we finally see her in number 9 WTF she's
a complete badass so if anybody believes
in the theory of the knight of the
Laughing tree that Lyanna stark defeated
a bunch of in the tournament to
defend the honor of Hal and Reed there
were a bunch of people at the tourney of
Harrenhal I know we've talked about that
a lot because it was R plus L equals J
stuff going on there Robert Baratheon
was there Elia Martell was there regards
wife that was Oberon sister the one the
mountain murdered we're gonna talk about
him in a second too but it's this really
cool story about how a bunch of Squires
were giving Howland Reed who is really
young at the time a bunch of in a
knight who was wearing the sigil of a
tree unhorse them out like beat the crap
out of all of them but it was a mystery
nobody could find out who the knight was
so one of the big theories is is that it
was Lyanna stark and she was a complete
badass also adding fuel to the R + L
equals J Theory forget about the other
stuff that was happening there because
if she was that badass of a fighter then
how could Rhaegar have taken her against
her will so it's not like she was
kidnapped so we can talk more about that
in episode 3 because that's gonna be the
tower of joy flashback gonna be a whole
bunch of Lyanna stark all over that
place so just try to hold your breath
till next week for that mirrors back and
we meet a new child of the forest I
think it's leaf the same child to the
forest from previous seasons they just
recast it and done more makeup like they
changed the night's king this night's
king is the same person from season 5 to
6 but the actor playing him has changed
the makeup has changed a little bit so I
think that's what's going on with the
child of the forest here just because in
the books the child of the forest
serves the three-eyed Raven is named
lief so if you confused as to why it
looks like a different person that's
probably why they just recast the actor
and just beefed up the make up the real
big change is Willis now that it was a
really cool reveal moment because it's
like oh my god is she talking to me but
then he looks through in it's Hodor as a
kid now what they've done is they've
changed his name from the books in the
books he's called Walder as in Walder
Frey because that's the area of Westeros
that he's from it's rumored that he
might be afrai through his mother's side
of the family but george RR martin
hasn't revealed that yet so he's Willis
on the TV show and Walder in the books
but number eight WTF so much amazing
Winterfell stuff happening Ramsay Bolton
kills Roose Bolton and in rapid
succession kills Walda and his little
brother you know I really prefer being
an only child
the minute that Roose died I felt like
we all knew what was going to happen to
Walden and that baby we just didn't know
how was gonna happen that that was that
crazy atmospheric music where he was
just standing there holding the baby
you're just like please don't don't let
him hold the baby but then he gives it
back so you're like okay but the minute
she goes into the kennel I was like yeah
she's definitely not coming out of here
but they kind of did the Sansa thing
last season you know where Ramsay does
something really terrible to a character
now doing it to Walder with the dogs
they cut away and look at Ramsay's face
you could make the argument that that's
even worse because your brain can come
up with something that's way more
terrible than what the TV show could do
and it also sidestep some censorship
issues even though there's not a lot of
censorship on HBO but number seven one
one versus the mutinous nights watch
such a great moment and you definitely
tell the Alliser Thorne never intended
to let them live those all those
crossbows training on the doors the
minute they would have walked out they'd
have been dead it's such a Three Little
Pigs moment where you hear this knocking
at the door and it just stops them all
cold in their tracks like wait a minute
but what's that sound
and then like jaws breaking the surface
of the water he just busts right through
the door and promptly boom they all just
drop their weapons he was so funny not
the funniest moment in the episode but
definitely one of the funniest funniest
moment number six WTF is the zombie
mountain getting his feet pissed on is
he just bashed that dudes skull not even
breaking stream that's a little classic
sometimes you'll see that in cop movies
where like a cop goes to arrest a drunk
person in the drunk person just turns
around and pisses all over their shoes
like god damn it number five WTF of
course is the standoff between Jamie and
the high
spero like you can definitely see that
there's a war brewing in King's Landing
when he says we could overthrow an
empire he's basically telling Jamie we
could overthrow the crown if we wanted
to so you're welcome to try and kill me
so it's only gonna continue to build
then you have Tommen who feels
completely ineffectual who might try to
rally but I love the look on Circe's
face here you can tell she's hiding
something from him like she has her own
violent plan that's brewing that she's
just not telling him about like oh it's
okay Tama you know don't worry you did
what you could remember she and Jamie
are twins so I'm wondering if they have
the same murder face like this is
Jamie's murder face that he's wearing
when he's talking to the high Sparrow I
wonder if Circe's murderface looks the
same number four WTF Arya finally passes
one of her big tests now she's going
back into the house of black and white
gonna continue to learn how to become a
faceless person that doesn't necessarily
mean her eyesight is going to come back
right away she's really close and as you
can tell they've been pushing into a lot
more mythology on the show especially
with the Melisandre stuff so they're
gonna continue to do that with the
many-faced God and arias storyline we'll
learn a little bit more about their
techniques a little bit more about their
magic there's a supernatural aspect to
what they do so hopefully we'll get to
see that in action just a little bit but
number two WTF meet your uncle ray joy I
don't fear the storm because I am the
storm so he is now the antagonist of
that storyline he's gonna be like the
person that you're a joy has to defeat
because even if you didn't feel like it
before you're definitely gonna walk away
from this feeling like she's the
underdog like she had that speech with
Balan I don't care what happened to
Theon he's still my baby brother she had
all his noble intentions ballons like
she's gonna screw that
what will March wherever I want to March
will try and take whatever I want to
take so right now she seems like she's
the only character in that storyline
that really cares about her fellow
Ironborn like she doesn't want them to
die she doesn't want to do anything
that's senseless we can take anyone and
see we're not so hot on the land the big
book scene that they did was Balon
Greyjoy dying on the bridge but in the
books a lot of people believed that it
was a faceless person that killed him
instead of euron greyjoy so the TV shows
just simplified it a little bit and it's
made it easier to see euron greyjoy as
the villain of this storyline just in
the way that he has that megalomaniacal
speech i am a god they fear me from Old
Town to Qarth basically making him seem
like the Ramsay Bolton of this storyline
so they set it out loud you know it's
come
Kingsmoot brace myself it's gonna be
awesome number two WTF tyrion is a
friend two dragons
he is like a fun size snicker bar just
standing right here I know a lot of you
are wondering because the way they cut
the trailer made it seem like he got
roasted like a certain character does in
the books there's just there's a like a
book storyline where the Dragons get
released but the character is someone
that the TV show cuts out so just assume
that they didn't do that storyline
because what happened on the TV show is
just completely different from start to
finish so I'll say it right now
everyone's gonna ask does tyrion being
able to get close to the Dragons mean
that he's a Targaryen is that why
they're so nice to him is that why they
don't roast him alive know as Tyrion
says they're intelligent they recognize
their friends I'm a friend of your
mother so I think they're just picking
up on that they just they sense that
he's not a threat to them it also
probably helps that he's such a small
person if the zombie Mountain had come
in to let them out they probably
wouldn't have been so nice to him but
the interesting thing about this isn't
so much that he releases them and is
like dude punch me if I ever think to do
that again it's that the dragons don't
do anything they just think they cut
away from that scene so you don't know
what happens but of course they're
teasing that the dragons are gonna get
out because it's like well they don't do
well captivity he's really only just
Unchained them they're still inside that
cage at the base of the pyramid so of
course biggest WTF Jon Snow came back at
the end of episode 2 how many of you did
not expect him to come back till much
later
I wasn't expecting him till episode 3
episode 4 but now we know that Sansa is
on her way to the wall so maybe we'll
get our first stark or union that'll be
awesome in the teaser for next week's
episode we hear tormund Giantsbane voice
saying they think that you're a god so
everybody's just gonna be in awe of what
happened so part of next week's episode
will be all the brothers of the Nights
Watch in the wildlings making this face
oh my god I can't believe it happened
you came back I did a whole bunch of
videos last season explaining
resurrection on the show there's a
couple different ways the characters get
brought back from the dead
White Walkers have their own version of
resurrection but it's not like the red
God resurrecting people it's not like
Lady Stoneheart
they're just there's so many characters
that come back from the dead in A Song
of Ice and Fire that the chances that
Jon Snow was not going to come back were
so small it was a pretty solid bet that
he would come back in one form or
another the big question is is how it
would happen
I think most of us felt like Melisandre
would be responsible we just you know we
didn't know when it was gonna happen but
I like the way that they made it so
ritualistic she's speaking all these
formal words she even cuts his hair a
little bit she treats the body I love
the way they use music during that scene
because it kind of Peters out towards
the end like you can kind of tell Mel
Sandra's spirit is leaving or she's just
like I don't I don't really believe
what's going on here I'm not really
feeling this and you get the her up from
tormund Giantsbane and everyone just
leaves the door slams but the whole time
I'm just looking at ghosts waiting for
him to react because you know ghosts
will go nuts if Jon Snow actually dies
like he'll just lose his mind with grief
so because during this whole thing goes
to just sleeping there calmly I was not
worried at all even if he wasn't gonna
come back in this episode it's not over
till ghost says it's over so let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode was it Ramsay just being the
most terrible person ever was it seeing
your on grey joint for the first time
was it John Snow finally coming back
even though I mean we all expected him
to come back and let me know if you
actually did bet money on Jon Snow
coming back I'd be willing to bet that
there are places in Vegas where you
could put down money on stuff like this
but I've never actually been crazy
enough to do something like that I think
the things I'm looking forward to next
week the most are the Tower of joy
flashback Jon Snow potentially meeting
Sansa just because she and Brienne are
on their way to the wall and maybe
seeing a big white Walker scene because
I was actually expecting to see him in
this episode but they didn't show up and
I don't usually take the time to talk
about it which is a big mistake on my
part but Game of Thrones has some of the
most beautiful exterior shots and a lot
of its CG so that kind of explains why
it's gotten so expensive there are three
in particular in this episode that come
to mind
one there's Mira looking out over the
frozen north just so calm and serene
look at all that dead space enough space
for someone with a giant army of white
walkers and whites to fill then we have
Cersei in the red keep looking to the
great Sept that was actually the path
that she was looking at was where she
did the penance walk her walk of shame
so it's almost like her path to war he's
also her penance walk visual metaphor
totally on point in all this seaside
Ironborn just making up for the lack of
Ironborn during season 5 it's big
sweeping landscape shots like this that
make you want to have a really big TV so
you just have it on in the background
silently so give
just a quick reminder there's a new
round of the giveaway happening now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
if you end up winning you can use the
money to pay your friends back if you
lost the bet about John snow there were
a couple people I did see comments every
once a while saying yeah I don't think
he's coming back but for the most part
we're all part of that truth are called
so we've all drunked the jon snow
kool-aid he is back now we can watch him
wreck the out of Ramsey Bolt in
this season really I do feel like
they're pushing Ramsey in a direction to
make you feel really okay with him just
getting steamrolled by John snow and his
army like they want him to be completely
irredeemable look at what he did to this
little baby in this helpless mother they
were willing to go off into obscurity to
live their life quietly and not
challenge his authority but he killed
them anyway so now divine justice will
reign down in the form of Jon Snow and
ghost so we're gonna be screaming about
this for like the next couple days but
I'll be doing a Q&A tomorrow so while
you guys wait for me to post that you
can click here to learn more about the
night's king in White Walkers a little
bit of their history and the Song of Ice
and Fire and you can click here for my
episode 1 video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you